- I don't trust anything
to hold these edges.
So really I just kinda Beyonce it.
"I woke up like this."
(air swishes)
(sign squeaks)
(upbeat music)
- The main thing I know about this gel
is that it is called Gorilla Snot.
Very aggressive marketing.
- I know very little about it,
other than it's supposed
to be a really strong hold.
- [Participant] People use this gel
for very extreme hairstyles
like a mohawk, or like a punk.
- So apparently, I'm supposed
to try some really great gel
that's gonna slay these edges.
I don't trust it.
This is a lot of hair and
I'm need a lot of hold.
- We've got some goob
action going on here.
- Ooh.
Okay, it looks like snot,
clearly.
- I don't know
how much I'm supposed to use.
- I'm a little worried
even the first amount
is gonna be too much.
- It's tacky the longer I put it on.
I can tell it's starting to hold.
- I don't know if this
is for my hair type.
- This is obviously, I think,
gonna be more of a wet look,
like a slick look.
- It looks like how I
definitely hate my hair
when it looks wet.
- It holds but in a different way.
It's 90% there.
- I think this will work
really well on a twist out,
or a wash and go.
Something where you're
actually trying to style it.
- I think I need to be around
a two on the hold meter,
and I'm on a 10 right now.
- I feel like there's a slick sheen vibe
that this could be a good nightlife gel.
- I'm gonna say that it's not my style
because it's very, very shiny,
and that wet look that I don't go for.
But I would give it a try.
- I'm gonna go throughout the day
see how it holds up, but
I'm confident that it'll hold.
- It just looks wetter to me right now.
It's hard.
It feels hard.
I don't know if this is what I want.
- So, it looks like the
general consensus is that
it's crispier looking but not
really all that different.
I will say that it held up well.
The rep that it gets
for holding it's grip is legit.
- Okay, so I'm not mad about this product.
It didn't flake up.
The little curls that
did pop up are shiny.
It didn't flake,
but this isn't something
you can just slap on and go.
You definitely would need a brush,
or a styling scarf.
- Unfortunately, I'm not
having the best experience,
but honestly, I do believe
if I had a hair dryer
it would've looked fine and perfect.
- I've had this hairstyle for a while
with the Moco De Gorila Gel,
and to be honest,
I'm not as mad as I thought I would be.
It's not a hair gel I
would use every single day,
but if an occasion comes, and
I need something stronger,
I know what to use now.
(sign squeaks)